welcome to this video playing haga from
Spain damn hmm or not he's not moving so
I'm always okay now he's going for me
six this guy is playing b3 all the time
this wide so um you think that he would
play me six as well and in fact he did
many fianchetto him yeah the double
fianchetto here for black is a very
solid way to play tongue can be
recommended Blackham has a very young
compact position no weaknesses
whatsoever and dumb he can try to play
for a b-52 or g5 this free moves in the
long run of course it takes a while
while white tries to keep his advantage
in space and tries to make sure that
those brakes are not happening under
favorable circumstances I read favorable
for black of course so let's see I can
always try to put something on d5 but
it's not the end of the world okay where
to go I could go to h4 I mean why not
why not age for tickle him a bit on his
heaven aha tickling successful
yeah someone pointed out that i should
say poking yeah i understand that this
is the better word but i still like the
tickling idea sounds sounds funny okay
he's got a weakness on d6 now really
quickly played the smooth surprisingly
quickly yeah but how to every night be4
would be obviously oh oh I can I can
maybe maybe I can play a bishop a 3 even
just Bishop a three ok maybe can we can
play Bishop e3 and then the d5
immediately d5 yes but not be five ok
let's let's do that let's do that it's
not it's not possible to invest much
more time d 595 was an idea
and many other possibilities Bishop a
one look T to other improving moves yeah
this is just the most them
direct way to play surprising those with
every thought that he needs to play t5
yeah this even queen is seven now as a
potential IDM queen is seven ask a
bishop eight maybe
interesting yeah i'm currently thinking
about the very air brutal move it before
just play b form okay come on let's
let's get head I'm tending b5 trapping
the rogue he goes a 60 play be five
anyway but you can take take take a 10 K
1 95 okay yeah that's bad then this is
this doesn't turn this doesn't really
help okay but the general idea is
interesting
I was so wound up let's let's go there I
just this is some Bishop f8 I can also i
can just go back to g5
now be five is a threat again I think I
didn't really didn't really help clean
yourself how do i how do i improve here
be five takes takes root k 1 Roxy 195
mm-hmm
94 come on let's let's plan it's running
time here and now this is aged 5 of
course and now I need to go back it's
great I mean age 5 is not necessarily
great for him but anyway
yeah that's that's just a whole who will
mess this game I certainly have led some
opportunities slip that this is quite
quite clear but I don't don't know
exactly how I should have played yeah
now I maybe get the d6 pawn but my king
position i don't i don't really like it
not sure what he's thinking about Queen
V 787s is big difference twinsies one is
very likely unser fashioned okay
check can give the check here he's a
taking only two
yeah this is a poem
Queen trade I would welcome oops I also
don't mind to win it huh this is lucky
black resigned yeah this was just a bad
game by me I mean I don't think around
he six is just just a big position of
mistake but I didn't really take any use
of that I mean it's it's not one of
those positions where this is new weekly
sd-6 is a weakness but I didn't really
made good use of that somewhere I mean
around here I was starting to drift
before intending b5 my tears 86 what I
didn't see is before I am that hear that
he's got this move of course and this is
just just awful this is hanging done
this is this kind of position it's just
it's just not good for me so I couldn't
do that we repeat it and now I tried
again to do something but it's not it's
not helping and here I don't really know
how to make any progress I play G for
which is maybe not not really helping
gather computer actually approves it
says it's about equal just probably
affair fairy zone changes yet yet it
irritated me this is hanging and this is
a computer wants to go Bishop c7 yeah I
taking the pawn maybe even I wanted to
have some protection of the king and tau
should just play am a queen move or
maybe take here you want something like
that and then you shouldn't have any any
problem at all but you just gave away
gave away the Queen here
blundering which was lucky yeah this is
a tough a tough construction this kind
of setup but here it is really a week a
week porn I should do something a bit
more sophisticated me trying to another
bishop a one drop key to look T 1 and so
on and then slowly try to build up more
pressure on the six what I did was
before I wasn't good alright thanks for
watching